not much is known about deep mind if you
take a look at their website you'll see
that their goal is to solve intelligence
and that they're currently hiring what
we do know is that having been founded
in 2011 they were then bought by Google
in 2014 for a whopping 400 million
pounds today they're publishing a major
piece of research in nature and we're
getting the opportunity to look inside
their offices we're not headed to
Silicon Valley but to the heart of
London we're behind a relatively
unassuming unmarked door sits on with
the brightest computing minds on the
planet one of the company's co-founders
is demis hassabis a chess prodigy
computer games designer and
neuroscientist with a passion for
artificial intelligence so we already
have serially we have photo recognition
computers are pretty smart but how will
this research take us forward even more
so I think all those examples you just
gave our examples of some smart tools
that we currently have but they're very
limited in their domain in terms of what
they can actually do and I think the big
challenge for a society over the next
decade or two is actually dealing with
the massive amount of data that you know
is being collected on everything from
healthcare to comics to climate and so
on and actually trying to make sense of
that data and finding the structure and
that data and the insights the negative
allows to solve whatever it is we're
trying to do and I think we're going to
need these type of aliens we're building
here in order to be able to find those
insights in that in a massive
overwhelming amount of data and the
paper that you're publishing now in
nature that starts down that path by
playing space invaders yeah that's right
so really it's just the very first baby
step towards that grander goal but
really the the paper and the work in
that
is the first example I would say of a
full system that can actually learn to
master a wide range of diverse tasks so
tell you through what the algorithm does
then step by step so the first time the
algorithm encounters a game it sees the
data stream for the first time so it's a
little bit like a baby opening their
eyes and seeing the world for the first
time so I'm the only information they
get is the pixels and the game score and
the goal they've been told is to
maximize the school but apart from that
they have no idea about what kind of
game they're playing what their controls
do what they've been controlling in the
game or it can do in the beginning is
trial and error press the buttons
randomly and see if they do anything and
then over you know several hours of
experience maybe even many days it
starts figuring out you know what it's
controlling in the world patterns in the
world building a model if you like of
the what how the world is working the
system kind of learns to adapt and gets
better and better incrementally to
eventually it becomes you know almost
perfect on some of the games and this
system that you've created can play not
just one of these games like space
invaders but a whole different array why
is that such a challenge
what's very difficult to build one
system that you know can can actually
master wide range of different kind of
goals so really the only way of doing
that is to actually have the machines
and the algorithm to learn for
themselves directly from the data to
find out more about how the algorithm
works
Demi's took me to meet two of its
creators Vlad and Corre
so if we were to peer inside this
algorithm what is it that we would see
right so the core part of the system is
a big neural network which essentially
gets frames from the game as input and
then it extracts layers of progressively
more abstract features so maybe at the
lowest level that would represent
information about which pixels are on
and when you go to the higher levels it
will start to represent positions of the
ball or maybe of the space invaders and
what the system produces as an output is
essentially a prediction for how much
reward does it expect to get if it
presses this key right now and continues
playing so we've heard a lot about what
the system is very good at doing and
that the certain games that it can play
what is it find more of a challenge
right so one issue with the current
system is that it essentially starts
playing the games but it just randomly
pressing the keys and in a game like
space invaders you can press spacebar a
few times and you'll hit a few of the
enemies and you'll get points but in
other games it's very difficult to get
your your first points or first rewards
so if the game involves solving a maze
pressing Keys randomly will not actually
get you only points and then the system
has nothing to learn so is that why it's
not quite so good at playing miss
pac-man so that's one of the issues
there there is amazin volved and it has
to explore the entire screen but it's
also a game where longer term planning
is initiated and so what does it find
long term cunning difficult because in
the current system it takes a short
history of what if it's played but it
doesn't have a real memory component so
it doesn't have any means to remember
but it has done far for
to the past so it can't use that to plan
far into the future either
this is just a problem of shared
computing power can we just give it more
memory um it is it is not that because
even if it has more like memory capacity
what is important is to be able to use
that memory capacity to actually decide
on what to put into that memory I want
to read from that memory and that is
there is a whole new aspect of research
that we are really learning to play a
variety of games is impressive but
clearly a long way off what we think
called as intelligence Space Invaders
may be an unusual first step but then
deep mind an unusual company
I joined Emmis for one last chat at
their weekly Friday drinks you're
punishing this research and the code in
nature are you giving away your secrets
to some extent well I think we as a
company you know we think it's important
to share these advances to the community
and we also think it's very important to
have an independent validation of the
quality of the work that we do and of
course you are
owned by Google why why why Google up
resume it's not just because of the
drinks on a Friday well you know Google
SEL cultures are very similar so there's
a lot of alignment actually with
Google's culture and deepmind's culture
but actually the main reason we decided
to join forces of them was to we felt
that we could accelerate the progress
we're making if you use the
complementary things Google found my
computing power and data and so on and
the things that we would get out like
the algorithms of salt and that's turned
out to be really the way that's
happening so it's been really really
good
well I think I get most excited about if
we look to the ten years plus out is
using the type of developing the type of
technology that we publish now and a lot
further and burning up those
capabilities so eventually we can have
say scientific advances being assisted
by a re either AI scientists or AI
assistant science and actually making
new breakthroughs with the help of
machine burning like the soil machine
actually do